[Music]
we like to do something nice for him I
thought would help our audience members
make a sale or connection by showing
some of their craigslist ads right here
on the show something a good idea let's
check out our first ad see what's going
on Oh check this out for hire like fresh
crackers in your soup I'll come to your
house and shake my beard over your bowl
next wash me I'm the third-base coach
for the Cincinnati Reds take me to the
ballpark now hiring whoa bass seeks on
fleek NSA FWB to explain to me what I
just said
am I the basis for the Smashing Pumpkins
I don't know
[Music]
needed less hot friend to complete our
squad hashtag squad goal and finally
seeking lawyer weird ball trumpet player
keep staring at me
[Music]
[Applause]
just keep it going yeah they seem
[Music]
you guys can talk in the commercial
break and work this out
you